it's kind of frowned upon that women may
consider you know the amount of money a
man makes before they make a decision to
date them and be with them is frowned
upon it it's kind of a shame because I
think as a woman you also want to
consider like your family your kids your
husband the lifestyle you want to have
for them like that also takes money and
I think sometimes we just think like oh
money materialistic things that's what
goes together but a lot of times we
forget money gives you options money
gives you the opportunity to look in
different areas money gives you the
opportunity to send your kids to private
school and of course that's going to
take sacrifice and time but again it
takes effort to also keep your
relationship any family if you have
money or no money like it takes that
effort and time is going to be
distracted and pulled away but I think
in a perfect world women are like you
know we just care about the man and of
course you want to have good values and
and have those things about a man but I
think you also want to especially today
with how expensive things are that
should be something important